Yeah, dude, but, uh, that's, that's it.
And my dog has got AIDS all over his face. Yeah, dude.
Butters is probably going to die, dude.
He butters looks like the guy from the Goonies with the bent ear.
He just looks like he's just a breath away from being like, Hey,
you ain't got hive, dude. He had a eye problem. So I took him to the vet.
And when you go to the vet,
you got to wait in the car and then the nurse comes out in your hand,
the dog over to the vet and then the vet walks it in and then you wait in the
car, like a big, dumb idiot. And I was,
and I'm in the car for one hour and then they come back and they're like, yeah.
So he's got an eye infection and I'm like, Oh really?
How did you figure that out? Cause his eyes all caked up. Why,
why why'd you figure that out?
Cause it's the only dog I've ever seen with conjunctivitis.
And um, and so they were like, just put these drops in it every three hours.
And so I did and it moved to his other idea. Yes.
Now it's in both eyes down. Stand on it,
stand in it. We need a little Lele. Oh dude. And that wasn't it.
So we started putting the drips in the second eye and then guess what dude? Oh.
Yeah, dude. It spread to his nose. How did it do it?
Hey, stop moving the light around, down there. Um,
and how did it spread to his nose dude?
His nose looks like a Barnicle,
so that's bad.
So it looks like some barnacles and his eyes look like they're
kicked up, kicked up eyes and nose Barnicle
and uh, so it looks really bad. So anyway,
taking him into the vet tomorrow and who knows if it's his last day or not?
In the meantime
trash dog Chen's uh, I talk about them. I still call them trashed dog on the,
on the, on the Rogan podcast. He's always going to a superstar,
a superstar. Hey, could you be more distracting down there?
I mean, Jesus Christ. Um, I took trash dog to the, um,
to the vet because why? Well, I don't know.
We found this dog. I told you near target,
like it was shopping for some placemats or some,
uh, and went to, uh,
when w w uh, and, and so, I don't know, all of a sudden he started wincing and.
I think he was probably abused, but I'm a savior. So I keep them in Miami,
keep them nice. And I don't, you know,
I keep them real nice and as frustrating as he is,
because he everywhere and vomits everywhere. I still hold my cool. And I'm like,
it's okay. It's okay.
And he barks and wakes the baby up and just everything do it. And I just go,
okay. All right. All right. Jen's it's not even his name. I made up a name for
trashed dog scraps, rat. Anyway, um,
runaway dude. So,
so one day he's, you know, you know,
a dog's in trouble when they're just like this.
What.
When they look like a, uh, uh, um, uh, private, uh,
when they look like Donnie,
Brasco the Johnny Depp at the end of the movie where he's like, no, no, no,
no. I'm a mafia guy. And they're like, what the?
You, you weren't aware what? Sorry.
Uh, mil I'm a dog. It's all good. ARF,
Ruff, Ruff, Ruff, Ruff Rover. Oh, a bone.
And, uh, guys in the van guys in the van just hearing are quieter. Huh?
Huh. Uh, and so, um, man, imagine being one of those guys in the van,
how important you feel and how dumb you look to,
because you're just so cooped up and you're,
and you're listening to the guy who was wearing a wire and you're in a flower
van. And, uh,
and so he was just chilling, not moving. And my girls,
like it, it's something we it's weird. And I'm just like, Oh, for sake.
Now you think something's wrong again? You know, I don't know. I don't know.
And I'm like, no, it's fine. You know, he's just a dog. He'll, he'll,
it'll be fine. He's just being really weird. And I'm like, what do you mean?
And she's just like, I dunno. It's just like,
he's just like really like cautious. I'm like, all right. She's like, yeah.
I think it's like for no reason. And just, I think it's like neurological.
Oh, all right. Cause you're a vet dude.
Chicks will just make up, man.
I think it's a neurological thing. Y you know, if it just.
Yes.
So I'm like, all right. So I take him to the vet
and then like, he pulled his back. Oh, really? That's neurological.
So he pulled his back. So she, she gave the vet, gave him pills.
Now I've got to give him pills, every, however many hours.
And he's got like three pills. Like he's some 80 year old uncle.
And, uh, they're in these blue bottles
and I go to sleep. I wake up and I look and there's
pill, pill, bottles all over the living room floor. And I go, what the?
And they're empty, dude. And this dog,
this trash dog ate 500 milligrams of whatever the
hell retinol is called. Like, it was some Funyuns dude.
And he's just, and I looked over him and he's just like this, but.
Uh.
It's all good. I am a regular dog in the meantime.
It's just ARF 20 minutes. Go by.
Oh, [inaudible]
rough. Rural
[inaudible] gunk.
No, but he didn't. He was chilling and I'm like, all right, let's leave him,
dude. He made his bed. Do the dog ate 500 milligrams of retinol,
whatever the it's called and my girl's leg, will you say good?
I got to take him in. And I'm like, dude, we found the dog. If he,
it was like the end of the Rocky where Dolph Lundgren is like, if he dies,
he dies. That was me. I was duffle longer than my trash dog. And.
I know you don't have a moral responsibility,
but I am a moral person and I am a moral and moral and I'm a mortal.
And so I was like, all right.
So now I got to take the trash dog to the
vet, to the animal hospital, which is by the way, you're a real.
And I'm just like, at least, no one's gonna be at the animal hospital.
Maybe the vet's closed. But dude, the animal hospital, the line was longer than
in and out. It was longer than what was the Christ chicken?
What's that place called the Christ chicken place? The,
the place where they don't, they don't believe in gays. What the is it?
Chick-fil-A those
so scared of Cox and buts. Anyway, chick, it was the,
like the line for Chick-fil-A and I got to go and I got park and now I'm waiting
again, my dog butters with the pink eye and barnacle nose at home. Just like,
I wonder where the trust dog went. And, and my dog is just,
and trash dog is just chilling in the, in the baby seat, behind my car.
Just looking at me. I'm like, this is not for you. Get the out.
Then the nurse comes with gloves in a mask. And she's like, is everything okay?
I'm like, just take the dog and see what the hell is going on.
If he's alive or not. And they're like, well,
we'd like to keep the dog for two days. I said, how much is that going to cost?
You? She's like, well, you know, you could take it for one day. And I said,
how much is it going to cost? He said, we'll call you back. Call me back.
It's going to cost four grand. Yeah,
four grand. Like it's some nice shoes.
Like it's a blazer. I got aware three times do it.
I'm not spending four grand on a dog. I found your target two months ago. Okay.
I already got barnacle knows costing me $800 on some eyedrops that don't work.
It's just making them worse. It looks like Matt Damon at the end of contagion.
And so now this dog, uh,
I got it. I'm like, no, bring the dog back. They're like, well,
we don't recommend that. Well, I said, well really well,
I recommend you giving me my dog back.
So I bring the dog back and that was just chilling.
They give them some charcoal. I don't know what the,
like he was bad at Christmas and they gave him some charcoal and they ate it.
Yeah, out black charcoal. They literally, well, his duck,
if his poop is black, bring them in. And I said, you just give them charcoal.
And they're like, well, okay, if it's black, like the next day, Hey,
after the charcoal. And they're like, you have to bring them in the next day.
And I'm like, I'm not doing that.
And then you have to also bring them in on the 11th. I said, I'm not doing that.
So guess what? He's fine. Where is he? Where are the trash dog?
Come here. [inaudible] come here. Come here, buddy.
Let's make your debut here. Come here, come here buddy. Good boy. He ran away.
All right. You know, you don't listen to me and you just eat pain meds.
Like they're Skittles. It's fine. It's fine. And uh, Andy,
any day you don't even affect him, dude. He's so, he doesn't give a, dude.
He's like you think pain meds. me. I'm dog. No way, man. No way, man.
I eat trash. I straight up a lead, a milk carton without the milk in it, man.
I don't give a dog when I leave your house.
And I run away. I eat all sorts of, leaves, trash,
Dunkin donuts rappers. And also I channel changers.
If I find that I don't give a man.
Bandanas COVID masks full of COVID. I don't give a man.
So I, uh, LA so I love this dog, I guess. I don't know, man. I'm a good guy.
Deep down is what I am. It was, it was my point. I took the dog.
I've found to the thing. Uh, I spent,
I think it was $900 on the guy and they wanted me to spend an extra four grand.
And I'm just like, dude, you know?
So I ordered this thing online.
This cup I have that.
This has made this, uh, it's really good.
You got to check it out. It's Emily Vander,
Mae V a N D E R M E y.com.
And you can order your animals likeness. She drew, she writes,
she draws it on the cup. She carves it into the cup. It's like a coffee mug.
It's really cool.
And she's going to do one of chenzhou they're good gifts. If you do it.
Emily Vander,
mae.com E M I L Y V a N D E R M E y.com
go there and you can get your animal on this mug
and I'm going to get chenzhou trashed dog on the mug this way. If he runs away,
I'm going to remember him by just having him on my cup. Cause.
I'm not looking for him again. If he eats more pills, he's gone, dude.
If he's more pills, that's his, man.
So you got to check that website out. It's really good. The way that,
the way she does it, you have to look.
I can't believe how good it is. They did.
She did one of butters and Sam too and Cooper and it's awesome. Anyway.
Um, check it out. Uh,
so yeah, so by the way, he's fine. Thank God.
I didn't give him to the four, four grand police. Thank God.
I didn't give him to the, to the, uh, cause he's okay.
I know they milk. You do it. I'm no conspiracy theorist,
but I know they milk you. Um,